[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعظم واطول واشهر وادي في الجزيره العربيه
وهو الاوحد الذي يقطعها من الغربي الى
الشرق هو وادي الرمه وهو من الظواهر
الطبيعيه عندنا ففي العصور المطيره كان
نهرا جاريا من مرتفعات الحجازي الى شط
العرب وفي العصر التصحر قطعه اوصاله
الرمال فتحول الى ثلاثه اجزاء وادي الرمه
وادي الباطن وفي عصر الجفاف تحول الى نهر
جاف ينهض ثلاث مرات كل مئه سنه ومع
التغيرات المناخيه بدا يجري على فترات
متقاربه سر لا تقف الدرب لا ياتي اليه
والحلم لا يجري لي يسقط في يديه هي هكذا
الايام دائما
للخلف تخسر ما لديك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومجرى وادي الرمه كان احد طرق التجاره
العالميه
قديما والرابطه بين اسيا وافريقيا وجريانه
له فوائد عده اهمها يجدد خصوبه الارض
ويغذي الابار ويخفف ملوحتها الملح يصلح كل
ما يخشى عليه من الفساد فاذا الفساد جرى
عليه فحمه
حكم الرماد
[موسيقى]